night at 8:00 Eastern on c-span 2
this morning New York Times reporter
Donald McNeil talks about his book Zika
the emerging epidemic and the latest on
the virus in the u.s. the hill
correspondent Reid Wilson looks at the
2016 campaign in the battleground states
and some of the ballot measures being
considered in the States a NASA
planetary science director James Green
discusses the mission and costs of the
Juno space probe to Jupiter as always
we'll take your calls and you can join
the conversation on Facebook and Twitter
Washington journal is next
two foreign policy speech is expected by
both Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
today mrs. Clinton who will be joined by
Vice President Biden will speak at 12:45
this afternoon see it on c-span listen
for it on c-span radio Donald Trump in
Youngstown Ohio he'll give a speech at
2:00 o'clock this afternoon you can see
that on c-span too and you can find out
more information about both these events
by visiting c-span dork a recent
Bloomberg News poll shows Hillary
Clinton has the advantage among
college-educated white voters Donald
Trump succeeds a most amongst those
without a college degree other polls
show similar results and there in the
next 45 minutes we're going to ask you
that question who do you plan to vote
for in November but here's how we're
gonna change the things around we're
dividing the lines by your level of
education so for those of you who don't
have a college degree two oh two seven
four eight 8,000 some college two oh two
seven four eight eight thousand one if
you have a degree from college - OH -
seven four eight eight thousand - and if
you have postgraduate or higher - OH -
seven four eight eight thousand three
and tell us who you're gonna vote for
also tell us if your level of education
affects who you vote for you can also
post on our web pages as well at c-span
w-j on our twitter page at facebook.com
slash c-span it's how you post there we
take this idea for the lines today from
a couple of polls that came out recently
one from Bloomberg News this is the
story that was published last week and
the headline says education level
emerges as a sharp dividing line in the
Trump Clinton Trump race and here's some
of the findings that they found that
when it comes to results Hillary Clinton
wins the college-educated segment by 25
percentage points as much 59% to 34% and
Donald Trump's edge among those without
a college education is 10 points that's
52% to 42%
Donald Trump's lead by the way is four
to one among white men with less than a
college degree 76% to 19% and Hillary
Clinton's advantage with
college-educated women if you compare
the two 64 percent to 31%
that's from Bloomberg and then Monmouth
University just last week put out a poll
as well taking a look amongst other
things about education levels and who
people might vote for it come this
November and here's what they found that
Donald Trump holds sizeable leads among
white men without a college degree
that's 31 points 56 percent of 25% white
men with a college degree
11 points 45% a 34 percent in white
women without a college degree that's 17
points also adding that these points
spreads are similar to how MIT Romney
did with these groups in 2012 they add
that among white women with a college
degree though Donald Trump is actually
trailing Hillary Clinton by 30 points
and Donald Mitt Romney narrowly won this
group by 6 points going back to 2012 so
again we'll ask you how you voted in
November and we'll get your input on
where you are educationally those of you
without a college degree call us at 202
7 4 8 8,000 if you have some college -
OH - 7 4 8 8,000 won if you have a
college degree - OH - 7 4 8 8,000 - and
if you have a graduate degree or higher
- OH - 7 4 8 8 thousand 3 we'll start
off this morning with Charles Charles
joins us from Florida says he has some
College Charles good morning your first
up good morning thank you very much for
taking my call I'm going to vote for
Donald Trump okay
what leads you to that decision but he's
gonna bring jobs back he's gonna get rid
of Isis and he's gonna he's gonna he's
gonna do all the things that he said
he's going to do when people watch
c-span not the media because the media
out now lies about everything
Hillary couldn't lies about everything
we got to have an honorable a person
with dignity and respect and Donald
Trump's a man I know he's an outspoken
person he tells it the way it is and I
wish America would wake up and it kindly
listened to Donald Trump when he says
not with what the lion scumbag media
says but well what would mr. Donald
Trump says because it it's really sad
the media should be held accountable for
what they what they what way they lie
and I'm surprised they don't get a
defamation of character lawsuit the
people who in charge of the media they
should be they should be going after big
time you know in Hillary
should because her and all those people
on that that what the hell you call it I
forget the name of it that convention
thing they the 99.9% of them light
through the teeth about him and and it's
really great art said so I think Charles
Charles hey Charles can I ask you a
question sure can tell us what you said
you have some college background tell us
a little bit about that
uh III got an atheist degree and skip
your mind that's as far as I rather
discuss I appreciate you know you
mention that and I got common sense and
if people think of it in a common-sense
way if they use their head for some
besides a hat rack it would be the best
interest for them and their kids and
okay
we got your we got you we got your
thoughts let's go to Chris Nottingham
Maryland postgraduate degree in higher
christen nodding him hello how are you I
am doing well thank you for se span so
I'm gonna be playing to vote for Jill
Stein and Green Party I'm a previous
Bernie Sanders supporter I've been a
lifelong Democrat but this past year has
been terribly disenfranchising of course
obviously is a lifelong Democrat I would
never vote for Donald Trump
for obvious reasons he is incredibly
far-right on the spectrum I'll just say
that what is it about is what is it
about Jill Stein and Bernie Sanders that
you find common ground with well Bernie
and Jill share a pretty pretty
consistent platform and their stance
against corporate money in politics is
equally strong I believe and I think
that Hillary represents just lip service
to that sort of tissue and I think that
Jill Stein call to to forgive student
debt is particularly valuable to me so
I'm a millennial postgraduate student so
I owe money like most Millennials I know
and patent a dose less than some but it
is barely significant in the way it
affects my daily life and I think that
from other millennial this is probably a
massive issue because
there very few other Mei believed very
strongly about each other progressive
issues but there are very few issues
that affect my life quite so directly
has the extraordinary amount of money
that I have to pay it what what do you
what do you got grants for most of my
back you might actually education what
are you studying Chris very good what
are you studying
oh so I finished study I got my master's
degree in environmental science
University law gotcha
you're breaking up a little bit so uh
thank you for calling them well we'll
let you go we'll move on to David who's
in Oxon Hill Maryland says he has some
college David hi there yes good morning
morning thank you some thank you so much
for c-span yeah I agree with the last
caller but I'm voting for Hillary
Clinton I consider myself an independent
and you know I've voted Democrat I've
voted Republican but I realized that
when when Democrats are in office the
economy goes up and when the Republicans
are in office the economy goes down and
the body count of of our servicemembers
goes up so you know I think in the big
scheme of things even though I don't I
wouldn't vote for Hillary if there's
Bernie Sanders was it was in a race but
I think that voting for Jill Stein and I
agree with her her stimulus package of
relieving student debt I agree was that
wholeheartedly but but I think I can't
waste
I can't risk weight wasting my vote I
think I think I think Donald Trump is a
danger I think he's a loose cannon I
think he's he's just trying to get back
at Ted and uh President Obama I mean I
think that you know if you look at the
big scheme of things you know the
economy it's bad because of the
Republicans in Congress not so much as
as the president so and there's no
president it's going to be perfect but I
think you know I think Hillary will do
it
job gotcha David tell us a little bit
about your college background yeah I was
uh 25 years in military and I got a lot
of my college I got almost a bachelor's
degree you know and from going to school
whenever I could
whenever I you know was had the
opportunity so I have an associates that
I'm working actually I'm going back to
school this fall to Paris my bachelor's
and what are you studying again I'm
gonna get it in business but my
backgrounds in electrical mechanical
technology again if you're just joining
us we're dividing the lines differently
according to your education level asking
you if who you plan to vote for this is
based on polls that are taken on these
kind of topics also asking about college
level of education and we're gonna get
not only your decision on who you're
gonna vote for tell us a little bit
about if your college background if you
have one or if you don't have one shall
it shapes what you do as far as how you
make these decisions on who you're gonna
vote for for those of you without a
college degree - OH - semper 80,000 for
some college - OH - semper 80,000 one if
you do have a degree - OH - 742 8,000 -
and if you have a postgraduate degree -
OH - 7 4 8 8 2003 The Washington Times
takes a look at the question of Donald
Trump's foreign policy a-team this comes
as a speech again expected today in
Youngstown Ohio this is the Post story
or the time story from this morning for
The Washington Times saying that Donald
Trump says he doesn't need and won't
hire any of the 50 Republican foreign
policy bigwigs who signed a scathing
open letter last week against his
candidacy but who does advise mr. Trump
on foreign policy and who might get the
top jobs in a trump administration it's
a question many are asking in
anticipation of the major foreign policy
speech that expected today
the biggest player it says was Senator
Jeff Sessions an Alabama Republican a
member of the Senate Armed Services
Committee who had a reputation for
bucking the party on foreign policy
points such as NATO's relevance and the
need for free trade deals long before
mr. Trump began underpinning his
campaign with them but to the extent in
which mr. sessions as guiding mr. Trump
on those issues and others including his
statements against Muslim immigrants or
his praise for Russian Plus and Russian
President Vladimir Putin remains unclear
that's in The Washington Times again
that speech out of Youngstown Ohio
that'll take place at two o'clock this
afternoon you can see it on c-span to
also listen for it on c-span radio and
then if you want to get more information
about this speech go to c-span org we'll
go next to Eric White Plains Maryland
post graduate student what are you
studying Eric oh yeah I actually have a
master degree in sociology and my minor
was in psychology and yeah that's what I
studied who do you plan for to vote for
in November
of course I'm voting for Donald Trump
and I also want to precise that I'm
black and I'm voting for Donald Trump
and I lost a lot of weight you know I
lost a lot of friends a lot of people
just because I'm black and I'm voting
for Trump I'm just so shocked because a
lot of people assume that if you are
assumed that if you black you have to
work Democrat and I don't just
understand my people you know I want to
tell them that you can be independent
you can make a choice we don't belong to
the Democrat you know and right now I'm
not happy about the press coverage I was
not born in America so outside of
American real estate we used to look at
the press at the media as the fourth
power but I've never seen such a
disgrace because the media has been just
so unfair I mean Clinton has a closet
full of skeletons but nobody talked
about it nobody everybody is cramped and
Franklin come on let me say I mean I'm
just asking the media to be say on for
the land you know he's not a politician
she's a businessman keeping the change
like the change was given to Regan you
know what would constitute what would
constitute fair coverage of Donald Trump
in your opinion a fair coverage of the
Natomas constitutes not just focusing on
his mistake because he's not a
politician who will always polish what
you need to care
the public but also focus on his
successes because I know the men have a
couple of bankruptcy but he also had
thousands of success meanwhile Clinton
came free week that we are learning that
about her emails and nobody talks about
it
I mean she's hiding to us that's our
next call is that was Erica this is Ron
Andrews North Carolina no College Ron
welcome to the program hi it's working
lands PhD who are you going to vote for
this November what and so why is it
about what is it about Donald Trump that
interest you the most well I tell you
I've been keeping up with politics on
Vietnam combat veteran and I I came back
now I'll kept up with politics you know
pretty close because it makes a
difference who gets us in war and so
I'll keep up with pretty good but when
you get somebody like Hillary that says
she had speech in Michigan those they
warned Michigan and she said I have your
back and I thought if I was an artist I
was asked her like he did in Benghazi
and she just lies and she and though
they got her on the video said one thing
but you get pertinent and so no I didn't
say that I didn't hear it like that and
so one more can't say well she told the
truth a couple weeks ago but she died
back step when she said she's going to
tax the middle class but I think the the
media is so unfair and I get so tired
you're about him attacking the gold star
family well that guy attacked Donald
Trump to begin with and why don't they
come out and tell about that cons
background he is a member of the Muslim
brother
he's been trying to get Sharia law
passed in the United States he is an
operative for the Democrats if I don't
somebody tell that side of it let's hear
from William in Waldorf Maryland I had
some college behind him William good
good morning go ahead thank you for
taking my call thank you for c-span I
just want to say that I think people are
concentrating on the wrong stuff
well not all people but both candidates
have stretched the truth quite a bit and
realistically the goals that they wish
to get done won't get done unless
Congress backs up so it's not about the
President's agenda it's about what the
agenda can do with Congress back in them
and if it's legal to the Supreme Court
so the rhetoric has always been extreme
the rhetoric has always been large in
part two with big faith but at the end
of the day you got three so who are you
going to vote for I'm going to vote for
mr. Clinton why considering what you
just said why her well because at the
end of the day she's worked with
Congress at the end of the day she knows
policy at the end of the day she good a
bad has been in the thick of it she's
been in the thick of it so why am I
gonna vote for someone that has not been
in the thick of it not been party to
expanding not just laws but getting
things done on the political level
William what's your what's your college
background tell us real tell us a little
bit oh well I've taken some college
courses while I was in the Navy and
taking some college courses uh since
I've been employed but I work 40 plus
hours a week and I'm in security weird
to say well your political observations
are where you find yourself politically
was that shaped by college at all yes
some was shaped by college but I had a
father that preached you have to watch
as many different parts of the media as
possible you had to read a newspaper and
when people gave speeches no matter how
boring you had to sit and listen believe
you mean when a ceasefire came on cable
my father had me down a watch so it's
that's where you've been Marilyn another
Marylander Joe in Silver Spring a
post-graduate person hi Joe
good morning thank you very much for
taking my closet you know I suppose you
spent what are you're thinking what
you're thinking as far as November is
concerned well I'll be perfectly honest
I'm to me the whole election is a
complete disaster I don't think really
there's much of a choice in this
election so I'm actually going to vote
for neither I think okay go ahead I
think I think Trump Trump doesn't know
charlie I don't think you know anything
about what he's talking about
everything he says changes from day to
day and with Hillary it almost changes
the same thing it's almost the same
thing is just a bit more subtle because
I mean there's you can point to the vast
amount of line I mean you can maybe you
can chalk it up to her being a
politician but a lot of my a lot of my
my disdain for her and I know she's got
the experience and I know she's been at
the top and I know she's worked with
Congress but it comes back to a lot of
the rock war which is very unpopular but
in the middle of the war one eye all
seems lost and we the surge was launched
she voted against it and and rallied
behind it and later
it was all for a political stunt so a
political stunt to gain political points
meanwhile losing a war to meet it
suggested that in someone who doesn't
really belong in the the highest state
of the land because the going is going
to get tough and tell us a little tell
us a little about your degree what do
you have it in though I have a master's
degree I have a master's degree from
from GW I did history and I was going to
ask people you know College shapes their
political opinion or how they think
politically with would that be the case
for you so yes yes and no in many
respects it definitely opened me up to a
lot of different perspectives at the
same time it's also it's also college is
one of those it's it's a wonderful place
it's a place where one gets to dream but
then there's when you get out there and
you work and it's really it there's
there's two very different perspectives
when you're through most of your life
working and then also what happens while
you're in college that's Joe and Silver
Spring the Wall Street Journal
highlights the visit and Scranton
Pennsylvania that will be made by
Hillary Clinton as she gives a speech on
foreign policy and the Vice President
Joe Biden saying that Scranton has long
been a solidly Democratic territory but
mr. Trump hopes to change that
capitalizing on the recent the region's
economic stagnation and anger over
illegal immigration for mrs. Clinton a
key challenge will be to prevent further
erosion of her support among
working-class whites a likely reason mr.
Biden has been tapped to aid her again
12:45 this afternoon at the time of that
speech you can see it on c-span listen
for it on c-span radio and you can also
get more information about this speech
and on the other events that we are
taking in during campaign 2016 at c-span
org here is Mac Germantown Maryland he
has some college Mac good morning to you
yes good morning how you doing EMC spend
this morning the comment I want to make
is is about these two candidates I'm
kind of leaning towards Democrats by the
way but unwillingness
unwillingly they think about mr. chrome
days I don't you know he's talking about
you know alienating the United States
and creating all the trade barriers okay
well will you look back people like
Donald Trump made lot of their wealth
trading out nor doing internationally
doing business with China and Bangladesh
and you know creating his product
overseas and bringing her back here to
sell it now he he's trying to create a
straight barrier and shut other people
out from using that very same
opportunity to to make wealth for
themselves I mean when I look around
today I see more of my friends more
people working for themselves today
because they are able they are able to
buy you know the tools and the necessary
things that they need to go into
business for themselves whether it's
cleaning gutter or what is you know I
know doing redoing in order homes
renovation the tools today are now
cheaper than ever been before because of
the trade with China and these are the
countries okay
mad you say you have some college behind
you tell us a little bit about your
college career well the thing is I went
to college of the University of Maryland
Eastern Shore but I never really got a
degree but I did a lot of college
courses because of you know unfortunate
situation in my life well I actually
started out that I was making too much
money to begin with as a college student
in the tech sector and I got sidetracked
it but when I decided to go back to
college for full time I had tragedy in
my life and I couldn't go well it's not
quite all tragedy but tragedy and you
know good good things also happen that
prevented me from going to college
gotcha Thank You Mac Fred off of Twitter
ads this is the conversation
this morning saying that he is a college
grad for Trump adding that Democrats at
the federal level are criminal I am NOT
voting or supporting criminals again
we've divided the lines differently by
educational levels and if you want to
choose one that best represents you and
give us a call and tell us about who you
plan to vote for in November we'll do
that for the next twenty minutes or so
from California this is Pam postgraduate
person Pam what is your educational
background well I have a undergraduate
degree from Cal State LA and I have a
law degree from Loyola Law School so
tell us a little bit about your plans
for November what you're thinking as far
as who you'll vote for I'm going to put
my nose in vote for Trump what led you
to that decision
the IRS Lois Lerner the Secret Service
stuff that just came out about the
alcohol and the coercion the emails the
State Department covering up for for
Hillary the Justice Department the
misuse of funds misuse of power
Bergdahl at the Bergdahl's parents at
the Rose Garden the VA situation that
was really painful to you know that you
said hold your nose and vote for Trump
who was the candidate of choice for you
I don't really you know what at first I
thought let's go with a non-politician I
never considered Hillary to be honest
with you because of way back I was one
of the few very few people in the United
States supporting a Monica Lewinsky
because I felt that she was 22
the president was fifty something he had
all the power I felt that the country
was against Monica and she was a girl
and she was being taken into the
president's bathroom and performing
sexual acts on the president and I saw
it as exploitation I
but anyway Hillary was out because she
coerced stuck with her husband and I was
in a long-term marriage I understand
maybe you have to but just the whole
thing let's hear from let's hear from
Steve Lewis Center Ohio college graduate
hello Steve how are you just fine thank
you for c-span thank you for taking my
call where'd you go to college the IO
State University
I majored in my major was accounting I'm
a certified public accountant a
certified information auditor and a
certified internal auditor gotcha what
you're thinking about November well for
me it's very simple it's a matter
it's about issues and the person who set
the agenda and as far as I'm concerned
has hit all the issues is Donald Trump
his rhetoric is a business man's
rhetoric he talks every time he gives an
answer he's already bargaining he's if
you know he's already setting the floors
most people don't understand his his
rhetoric but he understands the issue
and something about when you put a
microphone in his hand but I know more
by his kids
I think his kids say more about him and
his character and I think core values
are very important I don't have to agree
with him on everything but for me it's
issues and from that standpoint he has
all the issues now 106 million people
were qualified to vote in the 2012
presidential election and did not and I
think we're going to see those people
come out 72% of those people are white
by the way and I think you're going to
see the greatest turnout in the history
of this country and they're going to
prove that Abraham Lincoln was right you
can fool all the people some of the time
and some of the people all the time but
you can't fool all the people all the
time and that American people are very
trusting and I think they will figure
out and they will pick the best person
on the issues not the emotion the issues
what's the top issue for you and where
does Donald Trump fall in line with that
well I hate to quote Carville but it's
jobs jobs jobs and that's what I'll get
this economy going and you know you
start with that you
about energy security borders he has all
the main issues he set the agenda
whether people like it or not he really
does get it you may not like his
rhetoric he may go off because I think
he gets little ticked off about the
whole thing the way he's treated he's
not used to being treated this way he's
definitely not the establishment and
those people in the establishment are
scared to death what people should
consider is not only but he's going to
need support because as president he
also is going to need the help of
Congress gotcha gotcha Steve Robert in
Port Richey Florida a college background
college did you go to University of
Florida perchance Robert I did not what
my son did okay where did you go I went
to Duquesne University in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania
gods are what you study got a degree in
pharmacy I'm retired now gotcha
would you like in November I like Gary
Johnson okay for several reasons well
first he's uh he has executive
experience as being governor in New
Mexico and Andy was reelected so they
must have seen something him him there
also ditto with his his vice president
candidate weld yet wherever he was in
Connecticut or whatever but he's Fisk
fiscally conservative and socially more
liberal now I'm a moderate yet you have
to look at both sides of the coin and
the other the other candidates have made
such so many promises which every
candidate does that I think there's so
much animosity built up towards them
that I don't think they can work with
the Congress where Gary Johnson has
proven he could God your son who's going
to college who's he going to vote for do
you think
his wife I don't know we laugh every
time we bring up the name anybody's name
I'm trying to persuade him to go with
Gary gotcha
let's hear from Charles Charles in
Savannah Georgia
no college background Charles good
morning thanks for calling in hook the
government is at this moment here you
have you have and how the government you
have a president who doesn't know he's
getting the wrong information about his
army when he do find out nobody's fire
you have a Attorney General who goes
into the into people who she's been
investigated who's being investigated
and she has secret meetings with them
then you have FBI who all of a sudden a
person without intent all of a sudden is
not held responsible I can hold up a
bank and don't intend the whole of today
so I shouldn't go to jail now as far as
Donald Trump bills he should take all
these all of these are surveys that
they'd taken with him down and in front
of it and when it's in front of fizzle
audiences and tear them up at all these
meetings ago and let them know he's got
thousands of people showing up for his
events but when it comes to when it
comes to Hillary Clinton's events she
got maybe two or three hundred so you
have to figure the people that's
supporting from the shoulders that is an
event they have friends that don't
support I do support him and those that
are not being surveyed also important so
Charles
Charles you're gonna support Donald
Trump I'm after again it's a part of
look at government how can anyone
support a government where is it
completely crooked from top to bottom
you can't get look for instance you got
a da da da that don't don't prosecute
nobody you have a administration that
anytime you have a problem with the
administration nobody tells accountable
gotcha Charles peg off of Twitter says
Postgraduate here voting for Hillary
Clinton adding that watching a mentally
unhinged person get into the White House
is too frightening and pego Hsieh making
those comments off of Twitter this
morning if you want to post on our
Twitter page it's at c-span WJ and you
can post on our Facebook page too at
facebook.com slash c-span the Washington
Post has the story taking a look at
nuclear policy weapons policy
particularly actions behind the scenes
that are going on in college saying that
Republican lawmakers are seeking to
change or beef up nuclear defenses
saying that it all comes down to one
word and that word is limited that
defines the type of nuclear strike that
the United States guards against by
tightly controlling the number of
ballistic missiles in the country's
defense arsenal it's a policy focused on
threats from places such as Iran in
North Korea but now Congress is planning
to remove that word and potentially
replacing it with a more robust
substitute letting the next president
significantly ramp a production
modernization and development of defense
of nuclear weapons aimed at bigger
nuclear powers proponents of the
unprecedented change led by Republican
Representative Trent Franks of Arizona
and Senator Ted Cruz of Texas believe it
is necessary to help the United States
respond to increased threats from
nations such as Russia and China
Congress adopted the limited standard by
the way as part of the national missile
defense Act of 1999 at a time when the
u.s. ballistic missile defense was
already constrained by the now-defunct
anti-ballistic missile treaty since then
US relations with rival nations such as
Russia and China have worsened next up
Michelle from Oakland California a
postgraduate student hello
running facial how are you fine thank
you tell us a little bit about your
educational background liberal arts
nothing special but I did want to call
because I haven't actually have a major
complaint with Washington journal we
need to be talking about a lot of other
things other than these two candidates
there's a long way to November okay
there's a there's a riot happening
across the country okay we have lots of
problems and I think the c-span is
turning a blind eye to a lot of our
problems by talking about these two
people is an actor lunatic I don't
understand how anybody can actually vote
for him and Hillary Clinton is a thief
and a liar I'm afraid if I turn around
she'd be trying to play my silverware in
her purse okay okay let me address some
of your you cut me off and interrupt me
okay I want to see more black
representation on c-span okay on me on
Washington journal and I don't mean just
a little bought and paid for Congress
people I want to see more black writers
and activists and things of that nature
on c-span on Washington journal okay
you've made your point so let me address
them in time we talked about some of
those riot issues yesterday in our
program just letting you know that we do
have people who come from a wide
spectrum of racial backgrounds on this
program I've actually spent every single
morning and I'm sick of looking at the
same people with the same faces talking
about the same thing day in and day out
well let me just ask let me just ask you
to do this then go to our website type
in you know these concerns and things
that you bring up and see what comes up
and I'll show you that there's a wide
spectrum of diverse opinions represented
on this program now that's set to the
question a point where do you plan to
vote for November I want to hear from
Americans about things that matter to us
not about these two clowns running for
president okay you made your point let's
go to Dolores Collierville Tennessee no
college background hello Dolores good
morning good morning well I worked in
the factory that made furniture that
people use different kinds of furniture
and I do have to church and going to
college thank God and ever for that but
this is what I'm going to say there
setting up they're talking about Hillary
Clinton crooked Hillary
what about crooked Donald Trump look at
the jobs being ready to be lost by the
people up there that allows 3,000 jobs
they're not worth talking about that
that's going to be family members home
and everything is going to be in
jeopardy they said not talk about
crooked Hillary
what about crooked don't Trump stealing
from the people line said he was giving
money to the veterans and when he got
cold he go he went to try to put the
money in those places see I said I want
you all for many years and I'm proud of
the people you all have owned in the
wards to learn so thanks for calling
first of all who are you going to vote
for Hillary Clinton this November
that's what I was get rid of tario can I
have a few more minutes I know you're
busy yes I am they're setting up that
yes she's made mistakes she's admitted
they found her innocence of the crimes
they said she did I am sick and tired I
am sick and tired of them talking about
email those emails are not putting bread
on my table it's not helping my children
go to college with that these loans
outrageous for them to go wake up
America don't Trump is a con man he's a
liar he put his church a night there
what child won't get out there and speak
holiday parents they're not crazy he
they get out there and tell the truth on
their daddy he's going to cut that money
off its Dolores in Tennessee that what
USA Today takes a look at flooding
that's taking place in Louisiana
pictures from Youngstown Louisiana
courtesy of the Lafayette Scott Klaus
the photographer there adding that the
president officially declared a major
disaster declaration requests for
several of those parishes yesterday they
include East Baton Rouge Livingston st.
Helena and tanto phobia and that's
according to the station out there WAFB
the story in USA Today this morning
chris is up next Chris from Pine Hill
New Jersey some college background what
were you studying Chris computer systems
technology and I'm sick
credits shy of an associate's degree
okay but I'll probably never use it I'm
- the meanest mechanic and I was at a
manufacturing job and I'm getting like a
little bit over 25 dollars an hour and I
will vote for Donald Trump no matter
what unless I die but you know other
than that I will vote for him I've
contributed to his campaign mobile times
I got yard signs and my in my yard I
have t-shirts they're anti Hillary and I
won't tell you what they say
so what mistake is it what is it about
Donald Trump that won you over
everything except for one issue which I
profoundly disagree with him but he gets
a pass like he said he could sue someone
on Fifth Avenue and so far miles still I
will vote for him no matter what what's
the issue what's the issue then he gets
a pass in I don't like that with the
LGBT I'm a white male blue-collar
working-class I'm a baby boomer but I'm
a Christian conservative I don't think
he's authentic in every way except for I
don't know that believes that he's
really a true Christian let's hear from
mark up next leak Jackson Tennessee a
post-graduate person mark good morning
welcome to the program hi yeah that's
Texas did you go to you a University of
Texas no I would predict University
Purdue what'd you study there
engineering gotcha
you're thinking about November where is
it I'm gonna vote for Gary Johnson okay
why what led you to that decision well I
believe he's a logical and honest and
that seems to be Detroit and he also has
experience as an executive so as far as
people you voted for before would you
mind sharing as far as presidential
elections who you voted for in past
elections mostly Republicans
and was that shaped in college or where
you would always voted Republican or how
did that work no I that shaped as from
life experiences after college so you
voted for Republicans and now turning
around to Gary Johnson as far as your
support of him what do you when you talk
to people about your giving your support
to him what's the reaction that you get
oh well I don't really talk about it
very much I don't I normally don't try
to persuade other people
how about gotcha mark by the way you
should know that last week Gary Johnson
was a guest on our newsmakers program
it's our half-hour interview show that
takes place on Sundays if you haven't
watched it I invite you to go to c-span
org to watch that program listen to your
candidate of choice and see what he has
to say right can I comment more on the
issues if you want to pick one go ahead
oh okay I think the biggest issue in the
United States is the national debt that
if we don't get control of that then
that that all the other issues will
become irrelevant and I do believe that
mr. Johnson is the only candidate out
there that says has any kind of plan
that makes any sense relative to the
national debt let's hear from Tanya from
Washington State
good morning Tanya how are you good how
are you doing fine thank you
good I'm just up my degree I have two
college degree acts I have one in the
landscaping from the 90s to actually a
degree so she is degree and then I also
have a psychology degree and then but I
just wanted to I'm voting for Clinton
and a lot of the people have been
listening to and I also work with a lot
of elderly men and men and and a lot of
their responses a lot of them are going
for Trump and part of that it seems to
be because of the the old-school
thinking of like you know women belong
in the hall on this type of thing
and and so and they're just in Trump is
coming office again they're all thinking
you know like everybody saying you know
crooked Hillary well guess what you know
nobody's really looking into Trump's
background in fact that you know what
about all these students and everything
else that were left you know what is
heat you know and he is actually you
know not releasing the taxes there was a
reason for that you know and if anybody
wants to get into that there's you know
he's actually if if he gets to be
President
we're gonna be in a lot of trouble I
mean I think we're going to end up in a
war but one thing but daling I'm saying
and even some of the women that I'm
hearing I know and I know we go with
this educated thing but I'm sorry the
more even you know the more even if
you're educated in nutrition you're
going to eat them you know so shows
education regardless is always going to
give you a better edge and I think is
what's happening is just a lot of T's
men are really against women and it's
just in issues and I talked to so many
of them and of course they're polite to
me nice to me and they like me and and
and I don't try to sway their minds or
anything but it's at the same time you
know they they just can't get that
old-school mentality mentality out of
their head especially against women and
thinking that women or lesser than you
know and I am in Kenya on that lady that
brought up with it was Hillary's husband
about 10 years ago and you know what we
would in the past that was her husband's
my glory that did that you know and he
says I'm trying to say oh that poor 22
year old girl you know what the 22 year
old girl could have said no she walked
off I understand the power and I'm not
but don't be bringing up that kinda
silly stuff okay
okay Tanya you'll be the last call on
the topic a couple of headlines to show
you the lead story in the Wall Street
Journal this morning takes a look at
Democrats concerned about more
information that might be late by
websites such as Gucci fur and 2.0 word
Gucci 42.0 and WordPress you probably
heard the story over the weekend about
the legislators phone numbers Democratic
legislators phone numbers being released
concerns about more information being
leaked as far as especially towards
Democrats that's the Wall Street Journal
headline and if you go to the New York
time
this morning they take a look at Paul
Manafort Donald Trump's campaign
chairman especially ties to the Ukraine
and especially money collected and
things along that nature a story this
morning that appears at the lead section
of the New York Times our discussion in
the next segment turns to the Zika virus
the outbreak you've probably been
hearing about in Florida and other parts
of the Caribbean joining us for a
discussion on what the US is doing and
the federal response is Donald Green a
New York Times reporter he's also the
author of the book Zika the emerging
epidemic will take that discussion up
next and next later on in the program
will look at campaign 2016 and both how
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton are
fighting for common battleground states
and new ones Reid Wilson of the hill
will be along later for that discussion
as Washington Journal continues
throughout this month we're showing book
TV programs during the week in primetime
in case you're not familiar with our
weekend features book TV on c-span 2
takes our public affairs programming and
focuses on the latest nonfiction book
releases through author interviews and
book discussions our signature programs
are in depth a live 3-hour look at one
author's work with questions from
viewers via phone email and social media
in depth there's the first Sunday of
every month at noon Eastern afterwards
is a one-on-one conversation between an
author of a newly released nonfiction
book and the interviewer who's either a
journalist public policy maker or a
legislator familiar with the topic and
often with an opposing viewpoint
afterwards airs every Saturday at 10:00
p.m. Eastern and will take you across
the country visiting book festivals
author events and book parties or
authors talk about their latest works
book TV is the only national network
devoted exclusively to nonfiction books
book TV on c-span to television for
serious readers
the c-span radio app makes it easy to
continue to follow the 2016 election
wherever you are it's free to download
from the Apple App Store or Google Play
get audio coverage and up-to-the-minute
schedule information for c-span radio
and c-span television plus podcast times
for our popular public affairs book and
history programs stay up to date on all
the election coverage c-span's radio app
means you always have c-span on the go
Washington journal continues joining us
from New York is Donald McNeil he is a
science and health reporter for The New
York Times and also the author of the
book Zika the emerging epidemic joining
us now mr. McNeil thanks for joining us
thank you for inviting me so the title
of your book says it's an emerging
epidemic mr. McNeil but tell us where
are we as far as the US on this epidemic
as well
where is Zika concentrated and is it
spreading it's still emerging this is
the first year of the epidemic hitting
the SEM asphere it sprang out of Brazil
at the end of last year and has been
spreading northward and a little bit
southward it reached Florida last month
you know this there's quite a few but
more than a thousand travel related
cases the United States people who have
it because they went to countries that
have it but now we have local
transmission inside Florida what are the
common forms of transmission the most
common form is mosquito-borne
transmission that's the vast majority of
it and it's mostly the 80s a Gipp die
mosquito which is concentrated down in
Florida in the Gulf Coast although it's
found quite a bit farther in the in the
country but the CDC is assuming that
it's going to be limited mostly to this
of the mo topical parts of the south so
Florida all the way over to Houston
could be an outbreak in in Hawaii
because there's been a related disease
dengue in Hawaii but nobody knows yet so
as far as the danger second format Rios
go ahead sorry the second form of
transmission I should have mentioned is
sexual transmission mostly male to
female or male to other male there's one
known case of female to male
transmission and it's I mean this is an
incredibly sneaky virus nobody's ever
seen a mosquito-borne virus that's also
sexually transmitted and nobody's ever
seen a mosquito-borne virus that also
that attacks babies in the womb and
causes these devastating birth defects
basically either killing them or
destroying their lives I was gonna ask
you could you give us a further
explanation exactly what Zika is and how
it works yeah it's a it's a flap of
virus like yellow fever or dengue but
it's consequence it's and and for most
people who get it even children
even people with HIV as far as we know
anybody gets it it's a mild disease but
if a woman is pregnant literally at any
time in her pregnancy it appears to be
able to cross the placenta reach the
fetus and attack the fetus's brain and
so babies have been born blind babies
have been born deaf babies have been
born unable to you know ungroup their
their limbs clearly they're never going
to be able to to walk or to talk and
then the most severe cases have
microcephaly which is a tiny shrunken
head with an undeveloped brain inside it
some of those children died in the first
week of life some of them survived but
they have really very little life I mean
they basically can breathe and digest
but not do a whole lot else so it's a
real tragedy for those parents eyesight
those babies aside from the children if
an adult contracts it what are the
symptoms and and what is the likely
what's the the damage so to speak there
really isn't much damage if an adult
contracts it it's a it's a bothersome
disease but it's it's a it's a rash red
eyes low-grade fever hundred and two
hundred and three at most usually itchy
rash but it usually goes away in a week
to ten days there's about a one in 5,000
chance of Gihon bere syndrome which can
be quite serious quite scary it's a form
of creeping paralysis a little like
polio but it usually goes away and it's
also it's a wonderful one in four
thousand to one at five thousand risk
and that's you know we live with that
kind of that level of risk every day
even from you know being involved with
automobiles and things like that so that
that's not the most devastating
consequence although it exists of the
most devastating consequences to the
babies Donal McNeal our guest he's the
author of Zika the emerging epidemic and
joining us to talk about the virus what
we've seen in the u.s. other responses
as well if you want to ask him questions
you can do so on the phone lines
Republicans 202 seven four eight eight
thousand one Democrats 202 seven four
eighty thousand were independents 202
seven four eight eight thousand two and
post on Twitter if you want to shoot
comments his way at c-span WJ your book
mr. MacNeil what was the what caused you
get interest in this virus in the first
place um I was it was a slow week after
Christmas last year and I was looking
for an item to write and I suddenly saw
a headline out of Brazil that said you
know officials in the Health Ministry
had asked mothers in Brazil to stop
having children if they could and I was
just shocked by that you never hear
governments asking women to stop having
children because you know carried to its
extreme that's the end of your nation
and I thought what in the world is this
and I saw that they had they had this
outbreak of microcephaly in the
hospitals in Northeast Brazil and the
they weren't positive but the clearest
explanation seemed to be that nine
months earlier there had been this
outbreak of this mysterious
mosquito-borne virus that was actually a
relatively mild disease and so nobody
expected anything terrible from it and
suddenly the one after another baby was
being born with these horrible birth
defects and so I started writing about
it immediately and our Rio bureau chief
and Brazil cancelled his Christmas
vacation and started writing about it
too and we've been basically writing
about it pretty much full-time since
then from the responses that you've seen
on the ground particularly in Miami
Florida where we've seen some of the
news come out for the last couple of
weeks we've seen pictures of going you
know suited up met you know workers you
know trying to combat that tell us
what's going on on the ground there when
we see these pictures and things like
that what are we seeing well it's clear
that the 82 tip-time mosquito in one
part of Miami is transmitting the virus
the CDC and the state of Florida are
hoping that they can limit the epidemic
to just that one square mile of
territory and so they're intensively
killing mosquitoes in there whether or
not they can do that remains to be seen
Amy you know Puerto Rico is absolutely
overrun with a virus but Puerto Rico is
considerably farther to the south has a
lot more mosquitoes and doesn't have as
good mosquito control Florida has the
best mosquito control in the world but
that doesn't necessarily mean they can
beat this they had an outbreak of dengue
in Key West in 2007 and they started
fighting it when they do about three
cases but it still took two years and 90
cases before they beat it so we'll see
what happens
the
you know I'm waiting to see if the
confidence that they've limited it to
one square mile is justified I'm so what
they're doing is is basically all sorts
of traditional mosquito killing
techniques you have aerial spraying you
have spring of trees and bushes and you
also have putting larvae side into ponds
and bird baths and swimming pools and
things like that
to kill the juvenile mosquitoes but it's
tough to do Miami's a big urban area you
know fighting fighting dengue and in Key
West the Key West is a small island
fairly well-educated population fairly
wealthy this is Miami Florida it's a
very diverse population it's much more
crowded there are lots of people who
don't want federal agents coming out of
their property and killing mosquitoes
and you know are willing to say this is
my property and stay off it and I have a
gun and I'm justified keeping you off it
so it can be real tough to fight
mosquitoes in an environment like that
again science and health reporter for
The New York Times and the author of
Zika the emerging epidemic Donald Neil
our guest for a discussion on the Zika
virus
we'll start with Sally Ann in Florence
Alabama independent line Sally Ann go
ahead you're on yes hi good morning and
my question was in September of 2014 the
genetically modified mosquitoes were
released in Brazil to fight the dengue
fever so could there be a correlation
between the two could this have caused
the epidemic of the Zika virus
no the mosquitoes those mosquitoes the
the Oxitec mosquitoes are first of all
they're all male so they don't bite
humans so they can't transmit a disease
second of all where they they've been
released in a lot of places the Grand
Cayman Island Panama and some places
where they were released in largest
numbers in Brazil is 1,700 miles away
from where the epidemic was in Brazil
and mosquitoes only fly less than a mile
in their lives so 1,700 miles is about
the distance from here in New York to
Bismarck North Dakota so it would be
hard to believe that a release of
mosquitoes in Bismarck North Dakota
would cause an epidemic in New York and
I think the similar situation takes
place in Brazil you know just because
something is is genetically modified you
know doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to glow
like a jellyfish or that you know you're
you're gonna have the Terminator gene
that's found in seeds
there's really no connections between
the mosquito-borne disease and had
change in one small gene in mosquito
that causes it to die early which is the
modification that they made in that in
that mosquito gene Tampa Florida your
next Republican line Matt go ahead hi
thank you for taking my call and thank
you for c-span I had a question from mr.
McNeil he had as he had written or
covered the the partisan aspect of this
the bickering between Congress and the
Obama administration and not being able
to to pass some sort of budget for this
I see in the Washington Times that now
they're taking money out of cancer
research AIDS programs just to be able
to combat this is is that a temporary
fix are they going to figure something
out on this on a budgetary front okay
first thing I should say is that I'm a
science reporter my nightmare is cover
in Washington I let my colleagues in the
Washington bureau do that so I'm
watching this is sort of an interested
observer rather than as a political
correspondent you know money is needed
to fight epidemics whether its wine flu
whether its SARS whether it's Ebola and
and that you you know Congress has to
pass money in order to in order to fight
these things you can't necessarily pull
money out of one pocket very easily I
mean in the federal bureaucracy to fight
other things you know the only agency in
the federal government that has a lot of
discretionary funds they can do what
they want with is the military and I
would not be surprised if the military
is ultimately called in to fight Zika it
has been in many other countries in this
hemisphere they've got some
discretionary funding you know Congress
is that the Republicans attitude in
Congress has been take the money we gave
you for Ebola and use it to fight Zika
their thinking being